عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته.
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد
اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
[Silence]
صلاه حي على
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
ا حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
ইলাহা ইল্লাল্লাহ
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم
صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
والتابعين اما بعد معاشر فر الموحدين عباد
الله فان اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وان شر الامور محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه
وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار
اسال الله العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه
وكرمه وعفوه ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه
ولي ذلك والقادر عليه يا ايها يا ايها
الناس اتقوا ربكم ان زلزله الساعه شيء
عظيم يوم ترونها تذهل كل مرضعه عما ارضعت
وتضع كل ذات حمل حملها وترى الناس سكارى
وما هم
بسكارى ولكن عذاب الله شديد الحمد لله رب
رب
العالمين الحمد لله الذي بنعمته تتم
الصالحات وبع تغفر الذنوب
والسيئات وبكرمه تقبل العطايا
والقربات وبلطفه تستر العيوب
والزلات الحمد لله الذي امات واحيا ومنع
واعطى وارشد وهدى واضحك وابكى وقل الحمد
لله وقل قل الحمد لله الذي لم يتخذ ولدا
ولم يكن له شريك في الملك ولم يكن له ولي
من الذل وكبره
تكبيرا لك يا ربنا لك يا ربنا الحمد يوم
ان كفر كثير من الناس وارشدتنا للاسلام لك
الحمد يا ربنا يوم ان ظل كثير من الناس
وهديتنا للايمان لك الحمد يوم ان جاءك
كثير من الناس واشبعتنا واطعمتنا من رزقك
يا
الله لك الحمد يا الله لك الحمد يوم ان
نام كثير من الناس واقمتنا بين يديك من
فضلك فلك الحمد يا رب العالمين فلك الحمد
يا الله فلك الحمد ربنا عدد الحجر ولك
الحمد ربنا عدد الشجر ولك الحمد ربنا عدد
البشر ولك الحمد يا ربنا دائما
وابدا اليوم هو اليوم العاشر من شهر ذي
الحجه وذو الحجه وذو الحجه هو الشهر
الثاني
عشر ترتيبا في الاشهر العربيه هذا يوم
الحج الاكبر سماه الله تعالى بهذا الاسم
فقال واذان من الله ورسوله الى الناس يوم
الحج الاكبر وبهذا سماه سيدي صلى الله
عليه وسلم حين
قال هذا يوم الحج الاكبر وسمي هذا اليوم
بيوم الحج الاكبر لان فيه تؤدى معظم مناسك
الحج
الرئيسيه الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى جمعه
حج حج يوم الحج
الاكبر
الحجه الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم يوم الحج الاكبر
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم حج
حج هو ايضا يوم النحر سماه بهذا سيدي صلى
الله عليه وسلم حين ساله علي رضي الله عنه
عن المقصود بالحج الاكبر فاخبره انه يوم
النحر فقد روي عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
علي رضي الله عنه انه قال سالت رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم عن يوم الحج الاكبر
فقال يوم
النحر والسبب في تسميه هذا اليوم بيوم
النحر هو لان اهم الاعمال والعبادات في
هذا اليوم هو ذبح الاضاحي لله سبحانه
وتعالى ففي الحديث عن عائشه رضي الله عنها
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال ما
عمل ادمي من عمل يوم النحر احب الى الله
من احراق الدم انه لياتي يوم القيامه
بقرونها واشعارها واظفال
واظلافها وان الدم ليقع من الله بمكان قبل
ان يقع ان يقع من الارض فطيبوا به نفسا
[Silence]
‏sacriحه
وى صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
عائشه رضي الله
عنها صلى الله عليه
وسلمحر يوم الحج
الاكبر الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
before الله سبحانه وتعالى
لن ينال الله لحومها ولا دماؤها ولكن
يناله التقوى منكم هذا اليوم هو يوم ايضا
هو يوم فرحه وابتهال وتكبير وتعظيم لشعائر
الله واجلا له سبحانه وتعالى على ما هدانا
ويسر لنا الاسلام والايمان هذا اليوم يوم
تكبير وتعظيم لله سبحانه وتعالى ولتكبر
الله على ما هداكم وبشر المحسنين الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد بلا شك
اخي المسلم الفائز اليوم من عظم حرمات
الله وشعائره الفائز اليوم من اجتهد في
الدعاء والتضرع لله بخشيه واخلاص الفائز
اليوم من سامح وصفح عن الناس الفائز اليوم
هو كل من كان مخموم القلب صدوق اللسان
جميل المعشر جميل المعشر سهل التعامل دمث
دمث الخلق الفائز اليوم من ضحى وكبر وهل
وتصدق وتورع وسامح وواصل واتقى ودعاي
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه
وتعالى سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏speasy
people
الله اوصيك اخي اليوم اخي المسلم بوصايا
يسيت في هذا اليوم المبارك الا واول
واولها بصله
القربى بصله الرحم والقربى والاحسان
للوالدين واليتامى والمساكين لا تنسى
المظلوم اليوم من دعائك ولا تنسى اليوم
المحروم من مالك وذبيحتك وما جاد الله وما
جاد الله به
[Silence]
‏for
them also not
for those not
have
not blessed you have some of youry of
youralth of your
sacriiceicated and allocated for them
for the sake
of so those advices
ان شاء الله مايست خطبه بارك الله لي ولكم
في القران العظيم ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد
المرسلين اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم وارضى
عنا وعنهم اجمعين اللهم في هذا اليوم
المبارك نسالك من الخيرات اللهم انا نسالك
من الخيرات والبركات
والمسرات نسالك يا ربنا ان تتقبل منا
اعمالنا ودعائنا واضحياتنا واضحاتنا خالصه
لوجهك الكريم اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد في
الاولين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاخرين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
كل وقت وحين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي رايتي
الحق والدين الدين المبين اللهم ارحم
ضعفنا واجمع شملنا واجبر كسرنا ويسر امرنا
وفرج همنا واشرح صدورنا ووسع ارزاقنا
واقضي عنا ديننا اللهم تقبل توبتنا واغسل
حوبتنا واجب دعوتنا وثبت حجتنا واهد
قلوبنا وسدد السنتنا واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا
بفضلك يا رب العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا
ومرضى المسلمين وارحم موتانا وموتى
المسلمين وعاف مبتلانا ومبتلى المسلمين
واجعل لنا بكل دعوه اجابه وبلغنا رضاك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم اصلح احوالنا
واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم
اجعل هذا المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد
المسلمين اللهم تجاوز ز عنا السيئات وتحمل
عنا
التبعات اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم بارك لهم في اعمالهم
واعمالهم واختم لنا ولهم بخاتمه الاحسان
اللهم ومن توفيته منهم فارحمهم واغفر لهم
وافسح لهم في قبورهم مد ابصارهم اللهم صل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد واجزه عنا خير ما
جزيت نبيا عن امته اللهم احينا على سنته
وامتنا على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا
شفاعته يا رب
العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعدل
والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد
ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيم واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين واذ بوانا لابراهيم مكان البيت الا
تشرك بي
شيئا الا تشرك بي شيئا وطهر بيتي
للطائفين والقائ
قائمين والركع
السجود واذن في الناس بالحج ياتوك
رجالا وعلى كل
ضامر وعلى كل ضامر ياتين من كل
فج وعلى كل
ضامر ياتين من كل فج
عميق ليشهدوا منافع لهم ويذكر اسم
الله ويذكر اسم الله في
ايام معلومات على ما رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام فكلوا منها واطعموا الباء
الفقير
ثم ليقضوا تفثهم وليوفوا
نذورهم وليوفوا نذورهم
وليطوفوا بالبيت العتيق
الله
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ذلك ومن يعظم حرمات الله فهو خير له
عند
ربه واحلت لكم الانعام الا ما يتلى
عليكم فاجتنبوا الرجس من الاوثان واجتنبوا
قول
الزور
حنفاء لله غير مشركين
به ومن يشرك بالله
فكانما
فكانما خر من
السماء فتخطفه الطير او تهوي به
الريح او تهوي به الريح في
مكان سحيق
ذلك
ومن يعظم
شعائر
الله ذلك ومن يعظم
شعائر الله
فانها من تقوى
القلوب لكم فيها منافع
الى
اجل
مسمى
ثم
محلها الى البيت العتيق
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله
اكبر الله